Given that your person who tells stories
in the way that you do,
it's not like people just liked guns.
Why is this idea so irresistible to
American people?
Why?
Why isn't it like,
you know,
like you see sort of like a speech after
sandy hook or wherever.
And is that all right?
That's the day now where we don't have
guns anymore,
but it's just like,
no.
Why?
Why is this so powerful?
What does it mean to their,
which is a,
which is an excellent question and I
guess one of the best ways to explain it
would be,
and you touched on it there in terms of
tapping into some core things about how
America feels about itself.
They've got nothing to do with guns but
work quite well with guns.
So,
um,
when I used to go to the NRA,
I went to a couple of NRA convention,
the National Rifle Association,
which is the gun lobby and the vibe,
like weird,
weird.
I'm kind of,
um,
so a lot of white guys,
that's the kind of 90 percent of the
demographic,
probably more,
although they're trying to push guns in,
in more in women's direction,
so lots of pink guns and nice things
that you can carry your gun in and kind
of ways to look pretty with your guns,
stuff like that.
But um,
um,
lots of white guys and it almost kind of
almost sexual relationship to these,
to these weapons,
you know,
they're kind of the stroking them and
kind of,
you know,
the,
pouring them basically.
And I would really play up my
englishness in these things.
I mean,
first of all because it,
you know,
it helps and secondly because it
mitigates the blackness.
But you throw me now and I'm like
Downton Abbey coming out of your mouth,
you know,
from Steven and I've got another puff
daddy.
I'm looking at Puff Daddy,
but I'm hearing Downton Abbey.
If I could explain stevenage too,
then that would sort everything out.
So every,
most stevenage is a shitshow.
You can continue with your prejudices.
Crazy in Essex to stevenage and I that
understand this,
or rather I don't understand this,
I'm explaining it to me and to a person
they were off to the races.
They'll say,
are you married?
Do you have children yet imagined
someone broke into your house and they
wanted to rape your wife and kill your
children and take everything that you
worked for what you're going to do.
Uh,
you can,
uh,
waiver sticker them.
You're going to call the cops and wait
for the cops to come,
or you're going to defend your family
and defend what you meant.
And so it speaks to your kind of
masculinity.
Homestead,
a small government individualism,
a notion of kind of might being right,
defendable shows.
Now the reality is,
well,
there are several kinds of facts that
contradict that.
Especially most people who were shot
dead killed themselves.
Second day after that,
you're much more likely to be shot dead
by someone you know,
someone you've done so well I should say
is,
are you married?
Yes.
Well,
watch out for your wife.
And so,
um,
they are,
survey evoke these,
a very primal yes,
um,
things in the culture and when
confronted with that,
if you start talking about background
checks and um,
you know,
banning semiautomatic weapons and stuff
like that,
it's not really a match for the basic
ideas of American individualism,
small government masculinity and so on.
You're talking about tinkering.
We think so they,
they have a powerful narrative that they
can tap into and the gun control people
done.